uh hi hi do you mind speaking a little
bit louder i can't hear you over my
laptop's fan mails
yeah louder
yeah this is useless let's just launch
this thing two
one booster ignition and liftoff except
not anymore with this new macbook air
thanks to apple's new m1 chip inside
it's always completely quiet and cool
and there's no fan whatsoever do you
hear that
listen
silence
let's meditate
i've spent this entire week trying to
make this 999 laptop warm if not hot
i've completely failed same with this
new 13-inch macbook pro
i just couldn't get this thermometer to
read higher than the mid-80s i tried it
all up to 100 chrome tabs hours and
hours of gaming and video calling
if you want to make it hot fire up a
space heater
wanna actually hear a fan get one of
those
i'm gonna take you through all those
tests but first let's talk about why it
is this way with our first chip designed
specifically for the mac
and we call it
m1
m1 m1 m1 m1 m1 m1 has been optimized for
our most popular low power systems
yes it all has to do with this new chip
apple has put inside
see this macbook air and macbook pro
released earlier this year with the same
exact external hardware have intel chips
inside those chips are based on x86 chip
architecture i won't get too deep into
it but what you need to know is that
technology is more power hungry more
power equals more heat more heat equals
one noisy fan so now these are the new
m1 powered laptops the new m1 chip
inside is based on the same arm
architecture found in the chips of most
mobile devices including iphones and
ipads it's more power efficient less
power equals less heat
this new macbook air doesn't need a fan
because the chips stay so cool
the new 13-inch macbook pro has the same
chip but has a fan inside so it can run
a bit hotter and eek out a bit more
performance
see fans and computers cool the
internals to keep that high performance
running for extended periods so what
does it take to get these things heating
up
i did some testing
test one chrome which is known to devour
ram and processing power
opening 25 tabs
both the m1 air and pro stayed cool and
speedy 50 tabs
both still cool though the air started
to slow down quite a bit
now let's compare that to their intel
counterparts at 35 tabs the macbook air
started to sound like this
at 65 tabs this was the intel macbook
pro
and yet even at 100 tabs the new m1
macbook pro was sailing pretty smoothly
and completely silent
the m1 powered air i tested had 8
gigabytes of ram the pro had 16
gigabytes of ram intel said in a
statement we believe intel powered pcs
provide global customers the best
experience in the areas they value most
as well as the most open platform for
developers
test two video calling i held a
30-minute four-way video call via zoom
for some very important people please
mute
everyone please mute your microphones
and kept chrome running in the
background here's what the intel laptop
sounded like
and now the m1 laptops
speaking of video calling the new
macbook air and macbook pro still have
720p webcams though the image and white
balance has been slightly improved
test three gaming as soon as i fired up
code of war the intel macbook air revved
its fans
the m1 macbook air stayed cool and
handled the game surprisingly well
but with the m1 macbook pro i struggled
to get the fans to kick on at all
finally running a game while
simultaneously exporting a 4k video in
adobe premiere and some chrome tabs did
it
so yeah it's pretty crazy for years we
lived with laptops with whirling fans
and that made our wrists sweat and with
these that's pretty much all gone the
1299 macbook pro does have an edge
though not only because of its better
sustained performance but it also lasted
a crazy 16 hours on a youtube streaming
test the air lasted 10 hours and 45
minutes but you really can't go wrong
with either one so welcome to your
fanless cool future if you miss the
noise well
open this on your computer